[Music]
welcome everybody Welcome to Club
fugazi my name is mck Kara I am the
director of development at long now
Foundation Henry Farrell is a professor
working on democracy and international
Affairs at John's Hopkins University and
Henry's most recent book is called
underground Empire how America
weaponized the world economy after his
talk uh Henry will be joined on stage
for a conversation by Nils Gilman who is
senior vice president of programs at The
burron Institute and Deputy editor of
NOA magazine but for now please join me
in welcoming Henry
Farrell
[Applause]
so thank you so much all for coming here
and I have to say how wonderful it is
for me to be here this evening I've been
following the long now conversation for
years and it is just a genuine thrill to
be a part of that conversation in a
small way for just one evening this is
something that is very very exciting and
that makes me very very very happy
indeed so what I'm going to be talking
about tonight what I'm going to be
bringing to this conversation is this
discussion of as I put it in the
official title for this talk complex
aftermath of globalization and the idea
behind that title is fairly
straightforward you want to give a title
which gives a sense of the topic but
maybe doesn't say quite too much about
the topic so that people don't think
that they have an idea of what it is
that you're going to say so that they're
perhaps a little intrigued so that
they'll perhaps come along and see and
find out what it is that you have to
talk about and I've got a confession to
make which is that this is the official
title of the talk it is not actually the
working title that I had when I was
actually thinking about the talk and
trying to put together its themes and
its arguments I had a very different
title a title that is probably going to
be completely incomprehensible to most
people until after the talk is finished
which is that this is the talk about the
bagel and the poly crisis
now I can see already you know when I
worry that there might be a little bit
of a rush to the door how could we have
a talk which brings together these two
very different things by the end of the
talk you will have a good idea of the
logic of how the bagel and the poly
crisis actually fit together in ways
that make sense and that are not just
reducible to the piece of cheesy AI
generated art that I'm using to
illustrate the ways that the two
actually have sort of collide in some
way shape or form that is not the only
confession that I'm going to make this
evening the second confession and I
suspect that this is a pretty common
confession that is made or that should
be made by people who are giving long
Now talks is that I have a book to
promote this is a book which is
co-authored with Abraham Newman it is
called underground Empire how America
weaponized the world economy and it is a
wonderful book it is a great book it is
fun the financial time described it this
week as being a gripping book and it
gives you a important story about the
world it tells us how the world economy
how the world's Communications networks
how the world's manufacturing networks
all of these were supposed to be
decentralized in globalization and it
turns out that they get centralized once
they become centralized this allows the
United States to figure out ways to use
them as tools of uh coercion as Tools in
order to surveil the world and now over
the last few years we're beginning to
see what happens as other great Powers
as businesses as Ordinary People begin
to figure out what is happening and new
complex difficult and weird politics are
resulting and here's the third
confession this is the last thing you're
going to hear specifically about the
book during this talk this is going to
be your talk about all of the stuff that
I would have loved to have stuffed into
the books 288 pages but that didn't
particularly fit very well because it is
not the neede argument the neat Logic
the kinds of things that you can put
into a taught tense narrative it is in a
certain sense it is the book's weird
Cousin It is the weird cousin that comes
out of nowhere that grabs you by your
cardigan tells you urgently about all
sorts of stuff that it is insistence
that you need to know about that you
didn't know about before and that for
some important reason that it's partly
incomprehensible you need to know about
right now so what is the story that I'm
going to talk about this this evening
it's a very different set of questions
but it is a set of questions that really
touch upon this broader broader problem
of where we are after globalization what
I really want to talk about is America's
relationship with the world and the ways
in which American policy makers the
people who made decisions think and
thought about America's relationship
with the world and how they thought what
were the problems that they wanted to
solve on the one hand and what were the
means that they could use to try to
address these problems with the other
President Eisenhower when he left the
presidency famously gave an address
where he warned of the dangers of what
he called the military industrial uh
complex and so what he was warning about
here was not just the kinds of things
that we think about when we think about
the military-industrial complex today
the kinds of relationships between uh
military contractors in the Pentagon uh
Eisenhower was worried about that but he
had a much much bigger set of fears that
he wanted to express which was that the
United States was a a country where much
of the entrepreneurial energy much of
the scientific energy was effectively
being controlled by the federal
government was being directed by the
federal government's priorities by its
security needs and a lot of other things
were seen as being secondary unnecessary
or irrelevant and Eisenhower being a
moderate conservative a moderate
Republican worried about what this would
do to American Discovery American
entrepreneurialism over the longer term
and indeed if you look to see many of
the important discoveries that actually
began to come really into flower During
the period after this during the period
of globalization actually had their
origins in this military industrial
complex if for example you think about
the internet famously the internet is a
byproduct of Pentagon spending if you
look at Silicon Valley as Margaret omara
has documented in a really great book
The Code which I recommend that you uh
read if you haven't read it already
Silicon Valley and the commercialization
of the semiconductor were again
byproducts of military spending and the
need of the military for example for
sophisticated missile guidance systems
which led to the development of
semiconductors and similar Technologies
and then these of course discovered
civilian applications as well so this is
a period when the problem
primarily have to do with National
Security these are the problems that
occupy people's minds and the solutions
to that uh problem primarily have to do
with the exercise of the power of the
technocratic state so what happens when
the Cold War finishes when the Berlin
Wall comes down and all of these
wonderful things begin to happen we get
the Glorious dawn of globalization and a
very very different way of thinking
about the world when the Soviet Union
collapses relatively quickly the United
States finds itself in a world where it
does not have an adversary anymore
instead it sees an endless progress of
potential Triumph it has won its system
has won its system is being embraced by
everybody China may still be communist
in name but uh people hope and people
assume that as it Embraces the free
market it too will gradually become more
liberal and so you see a move away away
from security fears National Security is
certainly doesn't disappear the Pentagon
is still going strong but the
imagination of policy makers is
primarily focused on a different set of
goals that have to do with prosperity
and trying to generate it trying to
maintain it this is seen as a master key
to a better world now that the arrival
of the Soviet Union has disappeared and
the more that the world becomes
prosperous along us lines the better off
not only will the world be but the
United States will be too and we begin
to see of course the many changes that
uh happen as the United States begins to
push this as a different political
agenda and as different International
institutions begin to open up and begin
to embrace this as well so if the goal
is prosperity the a means to find this
is not through the technocratic state
the state to a very great extent recedes
into the wings and instead people start
to push for Solutions via free markets
via the market system Milton fredman his
justification of markets as enabling
individual Choice far far better than
States is something that is a plays an
extremely important role he and his
colleagues push for the notion that
markets are efficient and that state
intervention into the marketplace except
under highly limited conditions is a bad
idea also at the same time they enable
new forms of Discovery because the
market is this spontaneous order it is
far more conducive to open-ended
discovery of what people might actually
want than any system that is run by a
government ever ever possibly could be
so this logic is really the logic that
we see prevailing in how it is that
policy makers think about the US's role
in the world up until six or seven years
ago and it also seems According to some
people to have the answers are some
answers at least to now naal security
questions as well there's another
Freedman who's important Thomas Freedman
who is still writing for the New York
Times who in his arguments about a flat
world suggests that a world which is
based upon more and more globalization
more Market Freedom more Market
competition is going to be a world in
which Supply chains spread across
borders and as that happens the world is
going to be become more secure because
if you are looking to invade your
neighbor you are really going to be
cutting off your nose to spite your face
because you're going to be damaging your
neighbor's economy by so doing and you
are going to damage your own economy by
extension so this is a set of ideas
which prove to be extraordinarily
powerful as always they are more
complicated in the implementation than
they sound in the abstract but they
really do have important consequences in
changing the world and in moving the
United States to think about a different
set of goals to be achieved with a
different set of tools and in particular
the tools of the market that's your
potted history where are we now well if
we were in a world during the Cold War
where people thought that the government
knows best and we moved from that world
into a world where the market knows best
we're now in a world where famously
William Goldman said of Hollywood that
nobody knows anything that is to say
that we're in a world where we have
begun to realize that the many of the
promises that were made about about
globalization didn't actually turn out
to be true some did it did produce
enormous prosperity in parts of the
world which is incredibly important but
it has left a Welter of problems and of
extremely complex problems in its wake
so if you look at the way that the Biden
Administration is thinking about the
world it is very very clear that it has
taken this set of problems quite
seriously if you look at for example
speeches made by officials such as the
National Security adviser Jake Sullivan
our Katherine taii who is the US trade
representative AR Gina Rondo who is the
Secretary of Commerce all of these they
are singing from the same hym book and
there's a hym book which says
globalization achieved many benefits in
terms of I'm sort of providing
prosperity to the World Trade is good
and wonderful and so on but what we have
is a world in which this has led to many
unexpected problems proliferating and
becoming worse so they for example they
point to the ways in which the supply
chains that have spread across the world
turn out to be incredibly vulnerable
they turn out to be fragile when you see
something like a Corona virus happening
they also turn out to be possibly usable
by America's enemies against it as well
as although they don't stress this as
much for obvious reasons by America
against its own adversaries we also see
uh ways in which um climate change S of
is harder to tackle because of the way
that the global economy works and we see
uh very importantly the uh ways in which
changes have really perhaps even
endangered US democracy if you look at
the hollowing out of us industry in key
parts of the Midwest this is plausibly
part of the important story for why so
many voters became dissatisfied with the
existing system and decided to place
their bets on somebody like Donald Trump
and that is a story that we are all
living with today so the Biden
Administration is is looking decisively
to break with the old wisdom of
globalization with these simplifications
that I have described to its credit it
is trying to avoid moving back to the
previous simplifications of the Cold War
which are equally pernicious in their
own ways and it is trying to muddle
through it is trying to figure out what
are the new possibilities that you might
have to solve these incredibly
incredibly worrying problems that we
face that seem to perhaps endanger us
all so now I'm going to deliver on the
first part of my promise which is
talking about the poly crisis so if you
look at this if you want to look at the
problem side of the equation there is a
lot of value to a view that the
historian adom twos has developed
building upon an older concept called
the poly crisis to really describe why
it is that we seem to be in such Dire
Straits right now his idea is fairly
straightforward there are many many
problems out there we do not face just
one crisis we Face multiple crises at
once we Face climate change we Face
pandemic we Face War we Face some sort
of the weaponization of the economy we
Face vast changes in migration and all
of these problems are to some greater or
lesser extent apparently feeding on
themselves even worse they're all
feeding upon each other in some quite
important ways so just to take an
example if you think about the way that
climate change works it is plausibly
weakening democracy in certain countries
in Western Europe and we're likely to
see more and more of that happening
because as people begin to try to
respond to climate change they realize
that it's going to be incredibly costly
to make the transition to a post-carbon
economy and immediately bitter disputes
and fights begin over who is going to
pay that cost should we pay that cost at
all or should we just sort of put it off
again or hope that other people other
countries will pay it instead of us and
you again begin to see this as being
something that strengthens populists
strengthens the farri people who are
pushing back against democracy pushing
back against established ways of doing
things because they see this as being a
threat to their way of life similarly
you can see how climate change increases
the likelihood of migration people
fleeing parts of the world that are
becoming rapidly uninhabitable and so
tua's point is that these crisis tend to
magnify and exacerbate each other uh
that the economic aspects and the
non-economic aspect as he put puts it
are Tangled all the way down and that we
feel that we have so many different
problems competing for our attention
each of them enormous in their own right
so that's one part of bad news The Bagel
is the other part so here this is an
idea that I'm taking from Ezra Klein so
Ezra is trying to to diagnose the other
side of this which is that if T is
focusing on the problems Klein is
focusing on the uh parts of policy which
are intended to address problems and
he's coming up with a diagnosis that in
its own way is equally troubling What He
suggests is that our policy process in
the United States it's very very
difficult to get things done because of
the number of veto points that there are
and because of the tendency that policy
makers have uh because there are so many
different interests so many different
constituencies to try and large on
requirement after requirement standard
after standard in order to try and you
know sort to you know to use whatever
policy instruments are supposed to
achieve a single thing end up trying to
do 20 or 30 or 40 different things at
the same time so Ezra is somebody who is
a recent uh transplant from California
some of this is I think a very
explicitly an expression of his
frustration with the inability
of uh people to get things done to sort
of get planning permission to sort of to
do big things in California because of
how many different people have to sign
off but he also explicitly argues that
we see the same kind of thing happening
with the bigger geopolitical questions
so that for example he looks at the ways
in which efforts to try and get the
United States to produce semiconductors
so that it is not so reliant on the
outside world anymore and the risks that
you political risks that that involves
that these efforts to provide subsidies
to uh companies to set up semiconductor
Fabs they require child care facilities
and other things and so more or less his
argument is that the more that you try
to lard on these different kinds of uh
requirements the uh less likely it is
that your policy will be able to succeed
at any of them so in other words while
we have instead of these simplifications
that we had in uh different eras we have
these accounts of what you might call
impossible complexities from both ends
impossible complexities in the problems
that we have to deal it with impossible
complexities in the policy processes
that we have which are supposed to deal
with them and there are important
differences between the way in which
Adam TW and asra Klein think about the
world Adam tu's arguments suggest that
we need solutions that tackle multiple
problems at once Ezra clein suggests
that if we try to do this were probably
likely to lose focus but both of them I
think provide reasons for considerable
pessimism about our ability to confront
the massive problems that we need to
confront so where are we I think that
we're in a world where you know the
everything bagel is meeting the poly
crisis and we really need to start
thinking about what other possible ways
we might have to get forward and here
here again it's not entirely wonderful
you may have been able to tell from my
accent I'm from Ireland and so there's a
famous joke in Ireland at least famous
to Irish people I don't know if it's
well known in the United States it
concerns an American Tourist who finds
himself lost on the back roads the borin
as we call them of Ireland doesn't have
a clue where they are and finally
they're driving along and they come
across a farmer and they ask the farmer
how in the name of God am I going to get
to Liz dun Varna and the farmer looks at
them and he scratches his chin and he
thinks for a minute he looks in this
direction he looks in that direction he
scratches his chin again for another
minute he says well if I wanted to get
there I wouldn't start from here and I
think For Better or For Worse that is
the world we are in we are in a world
where it is incredibly difficult to see
what the ways for are that we might have
I can describe in the abstract the kinds
of policy instruments that we would
ideally like to have we would like to
have policy instruments that were
capable of first of all identifying the
complexities and representing the
complexities of the problems that people
like Adam TW described in ways that make
them actionable you have theories of
well here are the weak points that we
can go after then you would like to be
able to obviously address problems to
those complexities and then these uh
policies that address these problems you
would like to be able to rapidly revise
them it could be that they don't work as
you expect because your model is wrong
it could be that they work much much
better than you ever expected and you
want to build on them either which way
you want to be able to do these things
in a rapid and reactive fashion and if
you read people who write and who think
about the uh US Government like Jennifer
Pala you will see that this is not the
kind of policy apparatus that we have
are the kind of policy apparatus that we
are likely to have anytime soon so I am
not going to provide you with a specific
list of guidelines as to what we do next
what I'm going to do you know if I I I
am an Irishman but I'm also an academic
which means that I have some license to
be a little bit unrealistic at times as
well I'm going to say here are at least
some very very broad Pathways that we
might want to investigate further that
are possibly going to lead us in good
directions uh these are Pathways which
primarily identify ideas that have been
uh laid out by other people but that I
think as provide some promise as to ways
forward that we might want to think
about first problem centered publics so
what is the idea here well the idea here
is fairly straightforward during the
Potted history that I've described we
have had an emphasis on the technocratic
state on top- down leadership we've had
an emphasis on the Miracle of markets
what we have not tried ever to do in any
very sophisticated way is to use
democracy as a means of problem solving
and problem
identification and there is an old
tradition of trying to think about that
which comes from pragmatist philosophers
like John Dewey in the early 20th
century which suggested that a democracy
is as much as anything else it's a means
of knowledge creation it's a means of
information gathering and the intuition
behind this is pretty straightforward
that members of the public very often
they are not particularly sophisticated
in their understanding of deep causal
mechanisms of sort of complex factors
this that and the other but what they do
know very well and what is often very
valuable information is how it is that
these problems actually affect them in
their day-to-day lives and so then the
question is can you bring this
information that the public has together
with people who have expertise can you
create appropriate institutions and if
you can do that uh you can probably also
mobilize the public in ways that give
people a genuine stake in problem
solving that they don't have at the
moment so there are people who are
thinking about this in the early 21st
century who are quite different uh from
John Dewey but who I think are thinking
in a somewhat similar way there is a
wonderful science fiction novel that I
recommend that I have found influencing
my thinking quite a lot in this by a
woman called rusan emeris a half-built
garden what she's trying to do is she's
trying to imagine a world which is post
climate change where you see a
technocratic government continuing you
see people organizing around River
watersheds and she gives a vision of a
world in which you can use high
powerered sensors you can use some sort
of discussion debate argument fighting
AIS in order to actually get things done
and it is a you know this is a science
fictional Vision but it actually has
some very very interesting ideas about
how you might actually begin to apply
these things in the real world and not
only that but there are some fantastic
uh younger people who are trying to
think in very similar ways and here the
people pictured are Divia sidar and
saffron hang who have this collective
intelligence project which is really
trying to figure out how can we put
Democratic institutions together that
better take advantage of technology in
order to solve these big broader
problems another possible source of
insight cybernetics now I think that on
the left we're seeing a kind of a
romanticization of cybernetics which
might not be entirely ideal but
nonetheless I think there are some very
very valuable ideas in cybernetics uh if
you cut through some of the jargon which
could be revived and which I think could
help us especially as we think about how
to try to redesign bureaucracy so and
this is an Insight I owe to Daniel
Davies who has a great book that is
coming out on this next year people like
Stafford beer uh tried to figure out how
to rebuild organizations in ways that
made them more responsive to complexity
and the two key lessons that I think
that they have there is first of all you
need to have ways to actively represent
the complexity of the problem within the
system that is trying to uh resolve it
and secondly that you need to be able to
design feedback loops so that you are
capable of uh adapting rapidly to uh
whatever Solutions are needed and
figuring out on the Fly what works well
and what works not so well and so on and
so these kinds of design princip are not
the design principles that people think
about when for example they are
designing uh federal government agencies
they are not the kinds of design
principles that people think about when
they are designing businesses or
nonprofits there is a lot of work that
we could probably do to try and develop
this final idea Shas hurting okay so
this is perhaps you know even weirder
than the bagel and the poly crisis if
that is possible but uh the fundamental
idea here uh this is something that
Cosmos schy and I wrote for The
Economist a few months ago are
vigorously disagreeing with people about
large language models and other forms of
Applied machine learning are Ai and our
intuition is something like as follows
there are a lot of people who think
about large language models as being
some form of artificial general
intelligence in the making you you read
Sam Alman you read all of the people who
talk about this and there's this kind of
frenzied excitement about that many of
these people talk about large language
models the people who worry about AI
risk they talk about them as being shots
these are these sort of these shapeless
monstrosities from HP Lovecraft which
were created by these other shapeless
monstrosities and eventually rebel
against them and drive them into the
oceans and all sorts of unpleasant
things and so the notion that is
supposed to be communicated is that
large language models they appear to be
human but behind their human masks are
these bubbling monstrosities of
protoplasm which are going to devour and
destroy us if they ever get half a
chance so what cosma and I argue is well
you can think about large language
models and similar things as being shuts
in this sense but if they're shuts uh
they're not shuts because they're going
to become uh self-aware or intelligent
they're shets because they are
monstrosities in the same way that
bureaucracies and markets and even
democracy can be monstrosities that is
that they are these complex systems for
taking vast and incredibly irreducibly
complex uh bodies of human information
and creating useful but lossy
representations of them that is what
markets do according to hyek prices are
in effect they are lossy representations
of this uh much larger reality of
incredibly complex supply and demand
decisions that is what bureaucracy is
about according to uh James Scott who
deplores it uh bureaucracies again they
take this Rich no local knowledge and
they turn it into a thin slurry of
abstract Concepts that are actionable
and so what we want to argue is that
large language models and other forms of
machine learning their use is going to
be in taking bodies of information that
democracy has that is possessed in the
by the body of democratic citizens or
alternatively that is uh possessed
within bureaucracies and making it more
useful making it more readily available
by generating lossy but still
nonetheless useful summaries of the
information which provides possibly a
new set of ways of hand handling comp
complexity and perhaps uh enables some
of the uses of cybernetics some of the
uses of democratic publics that we
talked about earlier by providing
technologies that actually allow them to
work at scale potentially in ways that
they have not in the past so that's
where we are and I don't think that
these are particularly satisfactory
answers they really are less answers
than waving in the direction of
methodologies which may produce answers
one day and that means that we can't
rely on this on its own I think that we
do need to start thinking about and
focusing on immediate problems that we
can solve with the tools that we have to
hand but at the same time and again this
is a very long now way of thinking about
it I think we need to think towards the
future and we also need to think as we
are solving smaller problems we start
small but we want to think about what
are the destinations that we have in
mind what are the bigger tools that we
can build and how can we try to scale
these tools up over time so that they
solve the bigger more profound problems
that really challenge us that really
could uh in the end of the day destroy
us if we don't do something about them
so that's where I want to finish I want
to also thank many people and sort of
the if you have heard anything that
sounds to you even halfway intelligent
during this uh conversation this is due
to uh one of the many co-authors that I
show you in the slide or else
alternatively it is due to one of the
many people who I have collaborated with
on other stuff in the uh past or who
have just given me advice or whatever if
there is anything that is deeply and
irremediably stupid it is all down to me
so thank you all very much and uh with
that I guess I will finish the talk and
uh look forward to the further
conversation thank
you
I want to start by with a quote from KL
Marx um that many of you are probably
familiar with Marx famously said that
men make history but they do not make it
just as they please they do not make it
under circumstances chosen by themselves
but under circumstances directly
encountered given transmitted from the
past one of the things that really comes
out in your talk and in your book is the
question of path dependence like the the
the the way in which the era of te the
technocratic state the Cold War that
emerges out of you know the World War II
and the Great Depression era before it
the era of globalization and Market
centricity emerges out of some of the
failings of the previous system and
we're now living in the failures of
globalization and some new system is
emerging that we don't yet have a name
for so I'm wondering when you think
about that the way in which new systems
new macro systems emerge out of the
contradictions that engulfed the
previous system what are the limits to
the Futures that we have avail to us
long term that the poly crisis that
globalization has Beed us are imposing
what are the possibility spaces that are
not available to us anymore so that's a
very good question and there are a lot
of spaces that are not available to us
which might have been available 30 or 40
years ago and I think about this not
just in terms of uh past dependence
which is really how our past
institutional habits reinforce our
future ones but also just in terms of
resources that are on unavailable to us
are changes to the physical environment
which are things that social scientists
Like Me by and large don't pay attention
to we treat them as being constants and
of course they're variables and they're
variables which in many ways are going
in the wrong direction right now so I
think you if we you know if we had had
the intelligence to uh begin to tackle
some of these problems 30 to 40 years
ago I think we would be in a different
world equally and this gets to the
topics of the book more than it gets to
the topics of the uh talk that I've just
given if people had realized how much
geopolitical risk was going to be
involved in globalization uh 30 or 40
years ago it really would never have
happened and this is something that I
think turns to things that you think
about and worry about which is we are
now in a world where we need to create
more common systems to fight climate
change to uh figure out the transition
to a postc carpon economy and we are
doing so in a situation of profound
distrust which is a result of of
globalization having gone sour so I
think one of the big challenges we have
is you know given that we are in these
historical conditions which as Mark said
are not of our making what possibilities
for agency do we have can and this is
part of what we try to do in the book is
to say first of all try to get out of
the Spiral that you are in with China
where uh this mutual hostility and
suspicion you know so China's suspicion
is building on on the United States the
United States is building on China and
second
start to think about while you have this
power what kinds of collective Endeavors
can you apply this to which could
legitimate it and which could also
perhaps help to solve some of these
problems as well great great uh I I want
to put a pin in the question of what
should we do for a second and stay uh
instead for a moment about trying to
imagine what are the Futures we're
likely to get so what is the post
globalization future going to look like
there's been a couple of uh books that
have been published recently on this
that I think might be relevant for
thinking about this the political
scientist Steve Weber wrote a book A
couple of years ago called block by
block where he anticipated that we're
basically going to break away from a
single Global integrated Market into a
series of regionally defined blocks one
centered on East Asia maybe one centered
on North America dominated by the United
States maybe one centered on Europe um
and that we'll see much less trade
between these what's interesting about
that as a kind of a prediction of the
future of where we're going or a
forecast of the future is you know
people are talking about how terrible
globalization is but you know you
actually aren't seeing that much deine
in global trade yet you're seeing
changes in the global structure but the
actual numbers have not declined but are
we actually going to see that can we
actually I mean this is the path
dependency Point can we actually get to
a point where we break back to a cold
war world where we really have separated
walls I really don't think so I think
when I re read Steve's book I think
about that Kane's quote about how uh
people you know politicians who fancy
that they're completely free for from
ideas are caught up in the frenzy of
some Scribbler right and and Steve Weber
is one of those scribblers because if he
predicted what the conventional wisdom
was going to be which is the
conventional wisdom right now is that we
are going to break up into blocks I
think that there is probably more
evidence uh than in the public debate
that there is there are changes in trade
patterns happening equally I don't think
we're ever going to get into a world
that uh resembles the Cold War World I
think that the United States economy and
the uh Chinese economy are too deeply
Reliant upon each other for that to
happen and if you look at what the uh
what Sullivan and Rondo when she went to
China a couple of weeks ago are doing
they are really pushing for what they
call a a a small yard high fence model
in which restrictions would be applied
only to a relatively narrow set of uh
technologies that have obviously dire
strategic or military implications it's
going to be really hard to maintain that
uh because the problem is that the yard
is going to keep on getting bigger and
bigger and bigger
I think that uh if you look at the
policy debate in DC there is a huge
amount of fear of China but I also think
that the two have too much at stake in
each other's interconnections for there
to ever be a really really decisive
break so I think instead we're going to
get something which is you know if it's
like the cold war it's in the weird
ambiguities of the Cold War more than in
the uh sense of rigid separations of
systems it's it's going to be like a
kind of a John L Car Cold War where all
of the interesting stuff is happening in
the messy interstices and where people
are trying to manage these interes in
order to make sure that really bad bad
stuff doesn't happen Okay so this gets
us to the question what do we what do we
do about this um one of the things you
talk about a little bit in the talk and
also in the book is that you know what's
happened is because of these choke
points you're describing that go through
London or go through New York or go
through Northern Virginia choke points
that are Financial infrastructure Ure
that are informational infrastructure
the US and the argument you make in the
book is that the turning point is really
911 and the global war on terror where
initially we realize we can chase down
terrorists and and Chase down terrorist
Finance by monitoring these systems so
you have a whole narrative that you tell
about how this sort of emerged
organically out of sort of initially the
panicked moments of n post 911 and then
got institutionalized during the global
war on terror and you basically think
your argument I think is that this is a
mistake because it's going to drive more
paranoia and it's going to drive
separation and we're going to lose the
benefits of globalization with very few
upsides in exchange and you argue
instead that we should be thinking more
about these this infrastructure as a
commonwealth as a common shared resource
talk to me a little bit about how that
would look differently from what the US
the posture the US has been taking over
the last 20 years so this is one of the
areas I think that the uh final chapters
of books are there's a reason why they
are unsatisfying uh usually which is it
is really hard to come up with a
convincing and compelling solutions to
problems so I think what we offer in the
Final Chapter I don't think that we're
ever going to be able to get into a full
Commonwealth situation I think that
there is just too much hostility and
distrust and equally and this is the uh
side that it impressed upon me by uh us
uh officials who are grumpy with the
book and I think it is a very reasonable
point you so when they look at China
China is an authoritarian regime which
does terrible things to Wagers which is
not a particularly nice neighbor to have
and there are very good reasons why the
United States wants to press back
against China as much as possible and
why other countries if they were
thinking straight about this at least
other democracies would uh view this as
being uh very often a pretty good thing
so uh but we're never going to get be
able to get away from uh Power we're
never going to be able to get away from
the the fundamental fact that we live in
a world where there aren't International
restraints on power of that sort so what
we are looking for from the United
States is less that they give up the
keys to Empire then that they try not to
exercise it in Stupid Ways and they try
to exercise it for the common benefit so
if there is a ghost hanging over that uh
segment of the argument I think that it
is the ghost of uh another famous
economist Charles kindleberger who made
these Arguments for uh hemony back in
the 1970s and more or less what he said
is the United States is a global
hedgemon that is it is in charge of the
global economy but you need a Hedon
sometimes to knock heads together when
there is a crisis and to make sure that
everybody coordinates to do the right
thing if you had the United States
moving towards a model of hegemony I
think that will be a better situation
than the situation we're in equally if I
wanted to think about the good arguments
against what we say I think a lot of the
good arguments would be that we are
writing really from the uh perspective
of the powerful governments the powerful
states in the system and uh if you are
somebody who's at the receiving end of
some of these things even if it seems to
you plausibly that uh perhaps this is
sometimes going to be in the common good
it is also going to be in the common
good as defined by the United States and
there's also going to be a lot of
selfishness in that definition
International politics being what
international politics are so I can
imagine that uh we very plausibly and
very reasonably are going to get a lot
of grief and push back from people for
saying you know for not being a more
critical of the uh Empire than we are so
on the one hand as I say there are
people who I think are reasonably grumpy
at us some sort of from within the Biden
Administration and Elsewhere on the
other there are people who are
reasonably unhappy who think that we
give uh the US much too easy a time in
our argument and you know I think both
of those are reasonable points of
criticism when you write a book like
this you're obviously making a strong
argument but you're not making an
argument thinking that it is the only
appropriate argument out there you also
Al recognize that there are other
perspectives other points of view which
uh very reasonably are going to come to
quite different understandings of the
world than you do um I think one of the
things that's interesting about about
the position you find yourself in now
Henry is that you know if you look at
every decade there's always a couple of
key Concepts that become you can say
maybe the cliche of the era but the
defining kind of feature your argument
that you made in the book actually
started as an article that was entitled
weaponized interdependence and that term
I think could be one of those key
Concepts from the 2020s that in in
decades in the future people will look
back and say oh that was a really key
concept for understanding the era and
the reason why I say that is that
although you started you wrote this
article with Abraham as an motive
analysis it's now been picked up by the
policy makers themselves to describe
what they're doing you help them
understand what they themselves were
engaged in and gave them a vocabulary
for understanding and even though you
guys were kind of critical and you're
being critical now of this people have
picked it up and said yeah that's what I
want to do weaponized
interdependence and I bring this up
because this brings an really
interesting issue from a long now
perspective which is when you make
scenarios about the future one of the
things I always think about when I do
that kind of work is am I actually
making that future more or less likely
when I start to describe that future and
if it's a negative future you want to
describe it in a way that makes it less
likely to happen rather than more likely
to happen and I'm wondering if you had
any sort of misgivings about the way in
which this concept has been picked up
even though you meant it critically by
people who are now saying oh my God
that's what I want to do and you're
actually creating the future that you
were trying to ward off so this is
something that we think about and that
we worry about I think about it so
William Gibson has a famous uh dictum
the street Finds Its Own uses for things
I think what we have discovered is the
elite Finds Its Own uses for things too
and uh so one of the stories we tell in
the book I think think about this uh you
may be familiar with there's a famous
internet meme about the torment Nexus uh
this is a Twitter meme back when Twitter
was uh actually a service you wanted to
use uh where you have uh more or less
somebody describing uh you know science
fiction writer uh writes this novel
called Don't create the torment Nexus
and then a Silicon Valley company
announces we have created the torment
Nexus described in uh science fiction
writers don't create the torment Nexus
how awesome we are and so I kind of feel
a little bit like that with some of the
uses that have being made of the terms
so one of the things that was actually
quite terrifying for us was uh Chris
Miller who wrote this book called Chip
War which is a very very good book on
semiconductors uh which I didn't I
bought the day that it came out
terrified that I would discover that
what we were arguing about
semiconductors was completely wrong
happily that didn't turn out to be the
case but then I get about 3/4 of the way
book into the book and I discover Henry
Farrell and Abraham's Newman's name
coming up and uh so Chris who is uh
somewhat more on the conservative side
of the spectrum than we are uh talks to
an anonymous highlevel Trump official
who says more or less we read the uh
weaponized interdependence uh article or
I read the interdepend this article uh I
thought that this was uh in Chris's
description a wonderful quote game plan
unquote and then I'm sort of uh we went
and we implemented it in the
restrictions against Chinese companies
huawei's uh access to semiconductors
which has of course given birth to uh
Biden's uh Biden's plan and Biden's
efforts to restrict China's uh access as
a whole to uh the semiconductors that
are used to power AI so in other words
you so we found ourselves you know sort
of having warned as Chris says in this
book we found ourselves having you know
we warned you know this is something
that can be overused we don't want to
see the world becoming this world and in
fact it was used by Trump Administration
officials to do this so I guess the
constellation for this is is that I
suspect that something like this policy
would probably have emerged in any event
uh it would have been given a slightly
different name been justified in
slightly different ways but it's also
possible it might not have been one of
the real lessons that I think we learned
when we were writing this book is so
much depends on happen stance so much
depends on one official having a
particular idea at a particular time and
then this stuff gets set in stone and
there's another part of this which is uh
there's a part of the book you know
where I describe rist's ideas and I say
something like you if I say something
together with Abe something like uh uh
When people's ideas succeed they
degenerate into stale cliches that you
get in business best sellers and more or
less rist's ideas become you know what
you see piled up in fat heaps uh during
the 1990s and 2000s in airport book
stores around the world and so I also
have a kind of a feeling if if we
succeed uh we uh are only going to
succeed in the sense that people will
take up these ideas and perhaps they
will uh use these ideas but then there
are going to be other things that I and
Abe never anticipated that are going to
uh turn these ideas into the stale
cliches that a new generation of people
are going to rip down so that is the
academic life cycle and I think as I get
older I think one of the great virtues
that older academics like me serve is we
we excellent scratching posts for
younger academics to sharpen their claws
on and to figure out how to uh how to
get better you know how you know use as
target practice and if they're only
sharpening their claws and not using us
for other sort of possible functions I
think we're doing extremely well out of
the experience okay I want to take some
questions from the audience this is from
Joseph um he says do we have the
possibility of doing Mass collaboration
like Wikipedia to address these large
problems I think you were touching on
that a little bit in reference to Diva
and saffron's work and thinking about
the way in which we can use technology
and and large language models to do you
know to actually try to solve some of
these problems I mean we tend to see the
the ma majority of the discourse right
now around the impact of technology on
our democracies is that it's a bad it's
you know undermining you know we're
going to get massive amounts of deep
fakes and we're going to have massive
amounts of specially targeted
disinformation and so on but what are
the possibilities the upside
possibilities that these new technology
Suites are creating including large
language models but also new
collaboration tools for addressing some
of these challenges go a little more in
detail about that okay that's a great
question and I could talk for hours
about it uh and this also makes me feel
embarrassed because there's a whole
bunch of other collaborators who are not
on sort of uh in that last thing uh in
particular Melissa schwarzberg and Hugo
Mercier who are just wonderful academics
and we have a set of arguments around
this and here's and Wikipedia actually
features into the this uh story in some
interesting ways so Hugo Mercier I would
really recommend that everybody buy his
and Dan burber's book the Enigma of
reason I think this is the a stone cold
classic of the social sciences it is uh
and their argument is really good really
interesting they're cognitive
psychologists and they argue as follows
first of all human reasoning did not
evolve as a way of figuring out the
world it evolved as a means for us
providing plausible sounding
justifications for what it is that we
want to get in a social situation so we
you know we reason in order to come up
with good excuses for why what we want
is what everybody should want to so that
mean you that is a standard argument it
is a a source of cognitive bias it means
that we we but we are not
capable ourselves of detecting or
smelling our own okay so that's
part one of the argument the second part
of the argument is where it gets really
interesting which is that we are
terrible at detecting our own
but because this is so important you
know so because we are a social uh
species we are by and large we're pretty
good at detecting others and so
then this means that uh you can harness
people's cognitive bias against each
other so you and I disagree strenuously
on sort of I don't know who who who has
to pay for dinner I've got great
arguments on my side you've got great
arguments on your side but or but
probably at the beginning we don't have
great arguments I've got terrible
arguments and you round immediately on
the flaw in my argument and I round on
the flaw in your argument and it ends up
perhaps we uh converge to some degree
but at the very least we end up with
better arguments so the fundamental
notion here is that individual level
cognitive flaws can result in better
group level reasoning if we are prepared
to engage with other people who we
disagree with and so this then has
interesting consequences for Wikipedia
because what this is it suggests that
you can use people's Tendencies to be
as the fuel for actual good you
not collaboration but for actual I'm
sort of figuring stuff out and this is
in part the story of Wikipedia there is
a work that has been done by a Chicago
sociologist James Evans he uses uh he
and his colleagues use na natural
language processing to look at Wikipedia
and to look at the the amount of
disagreement there is on Wikipedia pages
and the uh fundamental finding that they
find is that the greater the degree of
polarization and tension that there is
in a given Wikipedia talk page the
better the quality of the resulting
argument so this is not because people
end up loving each other and singing
Kumbaya they still hate each other at
the end of the day uh but they
grudgingly recognize that there are good
arguments it's kind of like that uh
onion article of the uh person you know
the worst person I know just made a
great argument this is the logic that we
can actually harness to make Democratic
institutions work better and Wikipedia
because it is able to harness the
someone on the internet is wrong thing
and make that into a force of
intellectual Discovery is a very very
interesting model for us to do it that's
great um this is a question from marel
um she says the the climate transition
today is playing a similar role to
globalization 40 years ago everybody has
to transition the same way everybody had
to globalize what are we missing in some
senses we're we're responding to uh Kim
Stanley Robinson Stan Robinson who's
another wonderful person who helped
greatly to uh form the ideas of the
books you the Ministry of the future it
has similar ideas about central banks
we're not sure that central banks could
do it but it could be that this form of
uh benign imperialism could do it you
could make an argument that uh the
people who are resisting and pressing
back against this benign imperialism
don't realize that over the longer term
it is their in their interest to have
somebody who uh pushes them around as
long as this this uh this power does
things that sort of help towards the
Global interest equally you could see
ways in which uh the uh willingness of
the United States to uh get high on its
own Supply which is something that I
think is a characteristic constant of us
and you you you do not get anywhere in
US politics by uh thinking that the US
ever does bad things in the world I
could see this some sort of leading the
United States to uh overestimate uh its
degree of uh support in the world you
mentioned uh Kim Stanley who's given
long now talk on on this topic one of
the things I've talked to Stan about a
number of times is that one of the
reasons it's important to have you know
visions of the future plans of the
future even if they're totally out there
ideas that don't seem possible within
the current construct is that they can
suddenly become possible I mean he
imagines in the opening chapters of
Ministry of the future a horrible
Heatwave in India that kills 10 million
people in a couple of week span and this
is such a shock to the system that all
of a sudden possibilities for
institutional reform which currently
seem impossible become possible because
people are willing to consider things
because the crisis has gotten so acutely
bad um so there's a question here from
lesia Hendrick you know can a crisis be
averted within a short period of time
and can you imagine a scenario in which
the climate would be the thing that
would flip us into a new system that was
about much more International
collaboration or does that just seem
impossible given as an international
relations scholar you believe in the
Anarchy of the International System is
impossible to overcome there's always
going to be National rivalries that
Trump everything or is it possible in
your mind that a vision of the future
could be realized in a moment of Crisis
I think everything is possible and I
think that the fundamental defect and
flaws of the social sciences is that we
are stuck with the uh predictions about
the systems and the assumptions that we
make and we do not pay nearly enough
attention to contingency to
possibilities and you know I think also
of uh another great science fiction
writer Ursula lwin and the arguments
that she made you know she makes about
sort of well capitalism uh seems like
it'll stick around forever people
thought that the right of kings was
going to stick around forever a couple
of centuries ago and look what has
happened to that so I think that there
is always there is you know you can be a
pessimist as a social scientist and I
think social scientists tend to be
pessimists because in a sense our the
ways in which we think about the world
limit the possibility of agency we think
about the world in terms of big
structures and how these structures uh
of politics limit the ability of of
people to get things done and we don't
recognize the moments of contingency
when stuff can actually happen so I
think that we are the kinds of wisdom
that we offer is it is useful it is
valuable because most of the time we are
stuck in a world in which the uh
realities are as they are and we have to
try to uh we have to try and accommodate
ourselves to that and we have to try and
work within the systems that we have but
there are these openings up and so I
would have a slightly different version
of Stan's notion of the value of a book
like the ministry for the future so if
you look at how Adam describes the poly
crisis Adam TW describes the poly crisis
you he does say that one of the features
of poly crisis is that it is paralyzing
in this intellect it is intellectually
paralyzing and so I think the fact that
Stan wrote that book uh even if the
solutions very often weren't the
plausible solutions that uh you know
were going to reach some of them are
really interesting others like uh his
discussion of cryptocurrency uh he has
probably I think decided himself was not
a particularly good idea the fact that
you are beginning to argue about that an
inviting counterargument creates a space
for exploration of possibilities and
this is one of the things that I think
that good science fiction of that sort
has always been important in doing in
generating the sense that there and this
gets back to your first question that
there are possible Futures Beyond the
Futures that seem to us to be uh
inevitably as they are and uh and so to
the extent that we can balance the uh
you know so this is Graham sort of has
the famous line of course about the
pessimism of the intellect the optimism
of the will so you want to combine the
pessimism of the social scientist with
the optimism of the science fiction
writer in order to get a uh better sense
of you know yes it is really hard yes
99% of the time it is a miserable grind
you do not know what the better future
is that you're working towards but there
may be these sudden flares of
possibility where things temporarily
open up and uh new and crazy and
wonderful possibilities May emerge great
I think it's a great note to end on
thank you very much Henry frell thank
you thanks that was
great